bien sûr que nous sommes tous inquiets
bien sûr que on n'a pas envie de revivre
les moments de tension sociale que nous
avons vécu l'an dernier avec le
mouvement des gilet jaune
je dis simplement que 1 le gouvernement
parce qu'il alimente la confusion il
crée d'anxiété ensuite je pense que le
calendrier mal choisi présenter une
réforme des retraites juste avant les
fêtes de noël au moment les commerçants
les artisans vont faire leur chiffre
d'affaires au mans les français vont
faire des achats
c'est pas bon pour l'économie il ya
aussi une erreur de timing de calendrier
ça fait deux ans qu'on a de la
concertation deux ans qu'on n'a pas de
texte deux ans concrets de l'anxiété et
deux ans qu'on n'a pas réformé ce pays